khiter le stade tribales pour se
constituer en est à citer aux nations la
vengeance privée disparu au profit d'une
répression sociale l'état édictera des
lois destinées à protéger les individus
et leurs transgressions entraînera
souvent la mort dans des cas bien
définis
depuis le code d'hammourabi 17 cents ans
avant le christ les moyens utilisés par
les collectivités humaines au cours des
âges pour se protéger des criminels
n'ont pas beaucoup varié souvent en
affirmant son autorité l'étape où sera
très loin son souci de préserver l'ordre
public
on craint tout court l'état ajoutera et
cela depuis la plus haute antiquité
le crime de lèse majesté et le crime
politique la religion étant le ciment de
l'unité nationale l'état sanctionnera
très sévèrement toute atteinte à la loi
religieuse souvent par la perte de la
vie il y a un exemple éclatant de
condamnation à la fois politique et
religieuse celle du christ considérés
comme hérétiques par le sanhédrin de
jérusalem le christ doit mourir mais
dans la judée placé sous la juridiction
romaine le seul crime que l'on peut
imputer au christ pour entraîner sa mort
et le crime de lèse majesté
aussi devant pilate le grand prêtre du
temple fait il accusé jésus de s'être
proclamé roi des juifs et qui compte se
fait roi se déclarent contre césar
affirme les accusateurs c'est donc un
ennemi de l'empereur que pilate fait
crucifier en europe
jusqu'au xviiie siècle l'administration
de la peine capitale
rivaliser en plus hautes et l'expiation
était lente horrible humiliante
atrocement douloureuse en france la
suppression de la barbarie dans les
exécutions date approximativement de la
révolution française
le 31 mai 91 un projet de suppression de
la peine de mort est refusée à
l'assemblée constituante ou robespierre
qui compte parmi les plus ardents
avocats de l'abolition déclare que la
peine de mort n'est pas la plus
réprimandes des peines et qu'elle
multiplie les crimes beaucoup plus
qu'elle les prévient bien avant la
discussion du code pénal le 1er décembre
1789 le docteur guillotin avait
entretenu l'assemblée d'une machine
nouvelle avec laquelle il affirmait
pouvoir chaque santé la tête d'un
condamné en un clin d'oeil sans la
moindre souffrance par la suite
l'assemblée hésitant entre la potence le
gard ou encore appliquée en espagne et
la décollation mes deux premières peines
paraissant plus longue et cruelle
c'est finalement là
reilly suggéré par le docteur guillotin
qui fut choisi est le 25 avril 10 792 la
guillotine entrait pour la première fois
en action place de grève les exécutions
avaient lieu publiquement pour assurer
la valeur exemplaire de la peine de mort
c'est en juin 1939 devant la prison de
saint pierre à versailles curieux
l'exécution de redman en place publique
ce fut la dernière du genre toute une
foule en majorité composé de femmes
frémissait se bousculaient autour de la
guillotine pour mieux voir mourir le
ténébreux assassin lendemain la france
frémit d'horreur devant cette
photographie et le gouvernement pris la
décision de supprimer définitivement ce
spectacle morbide
depuis les exécutions ont lieu à
l'intérieur des prisons entre 1950 et
1970 il a été procédé en france à 57
exécutions capitales dont certaines
comme celle de jacques fesch en 1957 qui
tua un gardien de la paix et qui selon
un aumônier moureu comme un saint
relancèrent dans la presse le débat
toujours latent sur la peine de mort en
1969 jean laurent olivier périssaient
sur l'échafaud dans la cour de la prison
d'amiens
il avait le 17 juin 67 et tremblay et
violé une fillette de 11 ans est tué son
frère âgé de 10 ans l'exécution
d'olivier marque une date dans la peine
de mort en france
il a jusqu'à ce jour le dernier criminel
avoir été guillotinés depuis cette date
les condamnations à mort ont été
commuées en prison à vie par le
président de la république en europe
occidentale la france est avec l'espagne
le seul pays à pratiquer la peine de
mort pour les crimes de droit commun
reste le problème de la peine de
remplacement à la peine capitale dans
l'éventualité de l'abolition c'est un
faux problème dit robert badinter s'ils
ont le visage seulement sous l'angle de
l'exemplarité de la terreur comme
actuellement la peine de mort alors on
se dit elle fait peur elle est horrible
dans quel fai peuvent par conséquent
elle est dissuasive elle est utile et
alors le raisonnement se poursuit
si on l'abolît il faut qu'on trouve
quelque chose qui terrorise
de la même façon alors inévitablement on
est amené à inventer une forme de peine
qui terrorise qui launay tonnes et on
retombe exactement dans les mêmes
erreurs qu'à propos de la peine de mort
alors je ne peux pas croire qu'il y ait
de confusion le manipulation je dis
simplement c'est la constante dérives et
ses partis de l'idée
que ce qui est important dans la peine
de mort c'est en boire de dissuasion or
nous savons que ce n'est pas vrai et on
veut de la même façon rétablir une peine
qui soit dissuasive et on s'apercevra l
usage que ce n'est pas vrai le problème
de la sécurité des français la vie passe
évidemment par une réflexion et des
solutions autres mais une réflexion
d'ensemble et des solutions qui
devraient être comprises ça c'est là le
véritable objet du débat on vit sur les
années d'un code pénal qui remonte à
napoléon 1er bon les comptes mais aussi
à deuxième argument en faveur la peine
de mort c'est ce que j'appellerais le
prix du sang le certains appellent ça la
vengeance d'autres disent la punition du
galion le taillon est le talon à lire le
vieil instinct de mort chez celui qui
d'un seul coup et soulevé par la
patiente ce que l'on appelle le justice
immédiate
oui ça c'est une angoisse humaine
formidable et c'est en effet l'exorcisme
et ça c'est ce dont précisément justice
comme la nôtre s'est libéré et vous
savez nous sommes pas différents des
eaux je dire nous appartenons à une
civilisation commune nous français au
sein de l'europe occidentale
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes les
derniers pourquoi
il y a depuis avant-hier nous en
parlions déjà hier six condamnés à mort
dans les prisons france six
condamnations à mort en six mois ce qui
repose bien sur le problème de la peine
de mort invités du crible de daniel
grandclément ce matin maître badinter
qui est lui partisan ou le savez de
l'abolition de la peine capitale ça à
maître badinter qui aussi va sans doute
plaider à face il ya cassation les
dossiers des quatre premiers condamnés à
mort vous êtes donc l'un des plus
acharnées défenseur de l'abolition de la
peine de mort vous sembliez finalement
avoir convaincu pas mal de gens il ya
quelques mois puis tout d'un coup on a
l'impression qu'on assiste un échec
complet de vos thèses pourquoi jeter le
le soir du verdict de la sphère patrick
henry les journalistes l'interrogeaient
me disait alors c'est fini la peine de
mort qu'on n'aura plus à mort et je
répondais en disant pas du tout
l'abolition est certaine mais avant que
l'abolition soit acquise il y aura
encore des condamnations à mort et
peut-être des exécutions et mais là
c'est tout à fait étonnant le nom de
condom je répondrais de la même façon ce
n'est pas parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui les
condamnations à mort que nous n'aurons
pas - l'abolition demain le vrai
problème c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'en ce
moment depuis six mois nous assistons à
une cure sysmans évident de la
répression et je crois que c'est très
facile à expliquer entre le mois de mars
l'année dernière et le mois de septembre
la période octobre la période à laquelle
commence cette vague
vous avez eu la discussion des projets
sécurité liberté et pendant des mois on
a expliqué aux français grand renfort
d'image serait télévision vous rappeler
le petit bonhomme le petit délinquant
qui devenait énorme qu'ils étaient
constamment menacés dans leur sécurité
dans leur vie donc on leur a aussi
expliqué ce qu'était exactement cette
loi ici aux particuliers avec des gens
qui n'étaient pas pour cette fois oui
dont moi mais je ne parle pas là des
dispositions de la loi que j'ai combattu
et je continuerai à combattre je parle
simplement de la façon dont on l'a
présenté hier un amalgame qui est tout à
fait significatif et qui est tout à fait
détestable
pourquoi parce que si vous regardez les
chiffres de la criminalité tels qu'ils
sont et pas douteux qu en ce qui
concerne la moyenne délinquance
eh bien vous avez une augmentation et je
dirais que nous baignons réhab le
mandant
une société dans laquelle la délinquance
est considérable j'ai regardé les
chiffres avant de venir en 1979
nous avons atteint un million deux cent
dix mille vols sans violence 200 2000
vols d'automobiles par an 250 mille vols
de deux roues de sang a dit bref une une
délinquance moyennes et petites
considérable alors cela crée angoisse
exaspération sentiment d'insécurité mais
si vous regardez la zone de la grande
criminalité sanglante de profits c'est à
dire celle qui est directement concerné
que le problème de la peine de mort
ce que l'on a jamais dit aux français
c'est que depuis 1977
en ce qui concerne les meurtres
crapuleux c'est à dire les plus odieux
sur propos duquel on parle de peine de
mort comme menace dissuasive non
seulement ils n'ont pas augmenté mais
ils ont diminué au nez à tout petit tout
petit parti plan mais moi aussi j'ai
regardé le même mix que vous d'ailleurs
c'est à dire apports de la grande
criminalité en france
là je m'aperçois que la grande
criminalité c'est à dire que les hold up
le vol à main armée vols avec violence
tous à augmenter en 62 61 79 + 9 % et
entreprendre tous les actes eux à main
armée ou avec l'armée à chaque fois
s'augmenter avoir passivement une
bataille de gens se regardaient je fais
simplement marquer contre 1977 le moment
auquel a été publié le rapport
peyrefitte et 1979
le nombre des hold up que vous évoquez
et qui sont des estables et es15 180 il
est tombé à 12 131 4 579 ça remonte
c'est vrai pour les mairies de 67 mais
nous faisons pas cela devient simplement
que encore une fois quand il s'agit de
peines de mort puisque c'est d'elle dont
il est question
il ne peut pas être question le peine de
mort pour celui qui fait un braquage
symptômes on le sait dans les cours
d'assises
cela concerne exclusivement le grand
criminel de profits hors là vous avez
précisément une diminution
c'est un fait et c'est d'autant plus
important que je le rappelle en 77
monsieur peyrefitte lui même prôner
l'abolition de la peine de m qu'est ce
qu'il faut actuellement les jurés
dépasse presque systématiquement les
recommandations du ministère public
est ce que vous pensez que c'est normal
est ce qu'il ya de nouvelles réformes
apportées au système des jurés et alors
sur ce point je crois qu'il ya deux
observations rapide à faire ta briens en
ce qui concerne la cause de cette
réaction je les ai expliqué c'est parce
que on les entretient dans un climat
général
l'insécurité de quelque chose de plus
utile qui pourrait être fait depuis très
longtemps je pense que avant le début de
chaque session d'assises les jurés qui
arrivent pour avoir les plus
responsabilités les plus lourdes qu'on
puisse avoir devrait se voir renseigné
par le président l'avocat général
l'avocat au cours d'un séminaire
d'initiation à ce qui est à la fois la
responsabilité qui va être la leur
la façon dont les choses vont se
dérouler et les données actuelles de la
criminalité qu'il se renseigne qu ils
viennent là informer autrement le fait
c'est à dire par le récit des faits
divers
comment les moins de sensibilité et plus
de connaissances les choses allaient me
proposer officiellement vous allez
essayer de faire quelque chose pour que
ce soit de chez jamais cessé de le
demander j'aurai toute occasion le
plaisir de le faire je le dis encore une
fois quand on assume de telles
responsabilités la moindre des choses
est d'initier ce qu'ils auront à les
assumer à ce que seront ces difficiles
aux fonctions dernier dossier que nous
ouvrions aujourd'hui celui d'à peine de
mort car l'élection d'un président
socialiste change bien des choses en la
matière réécoutez tout d'abord sa
position telle qu'il exprimait dans
cartes sur table dans la conscience
profonde qui rejoint celle des églises
l'église catholique et les églises
réformées la religion juive
la totalité des grandes associations
humanitaires internationales et
nationales dans ma conscience pour le
fort de la confiance de ma conscience je
suis contre la peine de mort et je n'ai
pas besoin de lire les sondages qui
disent le contraire
une opinion majoritaire et pour rappel
de man et bien moi je suis candidat à la
présidence de la république et je
demande où une majorité de suffrages aux
français mais je ne la demande pas dans
le secret de ma pensée je dis ce que je
pense
ce appoint jade est ce à quoi je crois
ce à quoi se rattachent
mais mes adhésion spirituel ma croyance
mon souci de la civilisation je ne suis
pas favorable à la femme de porter pire
alain vous êtes avec nous en direct de
l'elysée monsieur badinter la maison à
la changer
oui daniel belani
le garde des sceaux a bien voulu
accepter de répondre à nos questions
directes alors d'abord monsieur le
ministre quel est le contenu de ce
projet de loi qui vient d'être adopté
par le conseil des ministres est ce que
la peine de mort est purement et
simplement aboli oui le texte est d'une
très grande concision
article 1er la peine de mort est abolie
article 2 dans le code pénal et dans le
code de justice militaire
homo peine de mort sont substitués les
mots réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
ou détention criminelle à perpétuité
puis un certain nombre d'articles qui
doivent disparaître du code ce qui
évidemment de n'être conditions
d'exécution la guillotine vous employer
le mot substituer ce ne veut pas dire
pour autant qu'il ya une loi de une
peine de substitution à la peine
capitale dont il ya simplement
l'abolition et par voie de conséquence
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
devient ce qui est la peine la plus
forte du droit français lorsque le
parlement leur a décidé s est ce que
vous ne vous rendez pas compte que vous
allez à l'encontre de l'opinion
actuellement en faisant en proposant ce
texte au parlement les frais
semblablement la mi-septembre le croyez
vous vous avez une situation dans
laquelle à deux reprises il ya eu des
élections le président de la république
s'est prononcé très clairement en faveur
de l'abolition
les français l'ont élu puis une majorité
de gauche l'a emporté aux élections dans
le programme de cette majorité étaient
inscrits en clair l'abolition de la
peine de mort par conséquent il ne peut
y avoir là aucune surprise cela fait
partie des engagements qui ont été
contractées par le président de la
république à l'égard du pays et par la
majorité parlementaire
dans ces conditions et bien ce que l'on
met en oeuvre
c'est simplement ce que la volonté
populaire a ratifié ce n'est pas
dissociable de l'ensemble
on a parlé de référendum vous savez
comme moi que ça n'est pas possible dans
le cadre de la constitution c'est au
parlement y lui maintenant de se
prononcer il appartenait au gouvernement
conformément à ce qui avait été la
volonté clairement exprimée du président
de la république de le saisir du projet
de loi portant abolition de la peine de
mort bien alors monsieur toubon est
notre invité aujourd'hui monsieur
badinter est ce que monsieur toubon vous
avez une fausse proposé à monsieur
d'attraction galian je ne veux pas
engager avec le garde des sceaux une
discussion que nous aurons sans aucun
doute à l'assemblée et notamment je
pense dès la semaine prochaine dans
quelques jours à la commission des lois
ont je pense le garde des sceaux viendra
exposer son projet je crois que je n'ai
pas lieu ici j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il s'agissait une question de
conscience
le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités c'est maintenant à tous
les parlementaires de la majorité
d'opposition de prendre les leurs mais
en tout cas monsieur badinter vous savez
que les questions de mon comporte encore
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
et d'être resté avec nous quelques
instants en direct merci beaucoup
quel honneur
au nom du gouvernement de la république
de demander à l'assemblée nationale
l'abolition de la peine de mort en
france
bonsoir il était 3h30 cet après midi
quand le garde des sceaux robert
badinter a donc prononcé cette phrase
qui rejoindra sans doute et grand moment
les grands débats des élus du peuple
qu'on soit pour ou contre la peine de
mort il est certain que ce 17 septembre
80 marquera une date voilà près de trois
quart de siècle que les députés ne
s'était saisi d'un projet de loi portant
sur l'abolition de la peine de mort
c'est des fameux débat de 1908 entre
jour et ses bars est entre-temps
nombreux furent ceux à batailler pour
supprimer la guillotine en france à
gauche et à droite et face à une opinion
hostile
françois mitterrand pendant la campagne
il ya six mois avait répété son
hostilité à la peine capitale
et c'est d'ailleurs l'un des plus
farouches avocats de l'abolitionnisme
qui l'a placé au mit à la justice et qui
se retrouvaient donc cet après midi
devant les députés
je dis simplement rappelant la phrase de
jaurès puisqu'à l'évidence en vous
sa parole n'est pas éteinte la peine de
mort est contraire à ce que l'humanité
depuis 2000 ans à penser de plus haut et
rêver de plus noble elle est contraire à
la foi à l'esprit du christianisme et à
l'esprit de la révolution et nous savons
bien que certains vous diront qu'en
votant l'abolition vous m'étonnez trier
la démocratie parce que vous mais
connaîtriez l'opinion publique
il n'en est rien le pays a élu une
majorité de gauche dans le programme de
laquelle figurait cette disposition
ce faisant le pays en connaissance de
cause
savait il approuvait un programme
législatif dans lequel se trouvait
inscrits au premier rang des obligations
morales l'abolition de la peine de mort
à cet instant lorsque vous la retrait
c'est ce pacte solonnel celui qui lit
l'élu au pays
celui qui fait que le premier devoir de
l'élu et le respect de l'engagement pris
avec ceux qui l'ont choisi
c'est cette démarche-là de respect du
suffrage universel et de la démocratie
qui sera la vo robert badinter ensuite
écarté l'idée d'un référendum serait
fait en se référant d'ailleurs au
général de gaulle qui était hostile en
la matière et puis il a réfuté
l'argument le plus utilisé par les
derniers partisans de la peine de mort à
savoir la peur peut dissuader les cris
il n'a jamais jamais été établi une
corrélation tel compte entre la présence
ou l'absence de la peine de mort dans
une législation pénale et la courbe de
la criminalité sanglant seul pour la
peine de mort
on invente l'idée que l'apport de la
mort retient l'homme dans ses passions
extrêmes
ce n'est pas exact et puisque vous avez
prononcé tout à l'heure le nom de deux
condamnés à mort et de deux exécutés je
vous dirai pourquoi est-ce que plus
qu'aucun autre jeu c'est qu'il n'y a pas
dans la peine de mort de valeur
dissuasive
ça c'est bien que dans la foule
qui à trois trios passe-passe de bull
fait de bons temps au tour du palais de
justice
amar pu faire à moi bon temps se
trouvait un jeune homme qui s'appelait
patrick henry croyez moi à ma
stupéfaction quand je les ai appris j'ai
compris ce que ce jour-là pouvait
signifier la valeur dissuasive de la
peine de mort
[Applaudissements]
le garde des sceaux a demandé qu'il n'y
ait pas d'amendement à son texte pas de
restriction par exemple pas de peines de
substitution et puis il s'est adressé à
ceux qui trouvent que décidément dans ce
genre de cas de conscience
on a trop souvent tendance à oublier les
victimes la mort et la souffrance des
victimes
ce terrible malheur la mort et la
souffrance des victimes
pour les partisans de la peine de mort
appel comme une contrepartie nécessaire
impérative une autre mort et une autre
souffrance
à défaut 10 est un ministre de la
justice récent l'angoissé la passion née
dans la société par le crime ne serait
pas apaisé cela s'appelle je crois le
sacrifice expiatoire
ceux qui veulent d'une justice qui tue
ceux là seront animés par une double
conviction
la première est qu'il existe des hommes
totalement coupable c'est à dire des
hommes totalement responsables de leurs
actes et la deuxième c'est qu'il peut y
avoir une justice
sûr de son infaillibilité au point de
dire que celui là peut vivre et que
celui là doit mourir est bien arrivée à
7h de ma vie l'une et l'autre
affirmation ne part est également
erronée aussi terrible aussi odieux que
soient leurs actes ils les points
d'hommes en cette terre dont la
culpabilité soit totale et dont il
faille pour toujours
désespérer totalement et quant à la
justice
aussi prudente soit elle aussi mesuré on
voit c'est que soient les femmes et les
hommes qui juge
rien ne peut changer que cette juste et
soit humaine et par conséquent faillible
alors après cette plaidoirie passionnée
une petite déception pour tous ceux qui
pensaient que le débat en valait la
peine les députés n'étaient pas tous
présents loin de là en revanche une
affluence record dans les tribunes du
public et aux abords du palais bourbon
le reportage sur place de daniel brême
et de jean-louis le sel c'était sans
doute l'occasion cet après-midi pour
robert badinter de faire la plaidoirie
dont il rêvait depuis longtemps sa
meilleure plaidoirie selon ses
conseillers au ministère de la justice
mais pendant ce temps à l'extérieur le
public invité attendaient de pouvoir
pénétrer dans l'hémicycle un public
partagé plus partagée que les sondages
veulent bien le dire ou le laisser
croire
suis pour la peine demande si ça me
touche est prêt à froid n'ont
effectivement c'est un pas très sain
mais ce que je peux par contre je suis
pour un débat sur la peine de mort alors
que les gens quittent une lan débattent
pas tellement et je suis contre les
critères d'appréciation d'à peine de
mort de crime particulièrement horrible
tous les crimes quant au riz par mon
avis par exemple un crime d'agents de
police c'est aussi horrible car un crime
d'une personne privée je vois pourquoi
il y aurait une peine de mort pour celui
qui tue un agent de police mais pas pour
celui qui tue une grand-mère pour l'ebit
qui rend chaque projet trop contente
qu'on condamne pas suffisamment les
autres social tel qu'il soit donc vous
êtes pour le maintien mais vainement oui
parce qu'on les condamne à 25 ans 30 ans
et au bout de 15 ans 20 ans ils sortent
qu'est ce que vous voyez vous comme
femmes de remplacement personnellement
la prison à vie
en fait qu'est ce que c'est
l'emprisonnement quelle est sa
ces véritables valeurs est-ce que c'est
pour punir les gens ou est ce que c'est
pour les faire changer est ce que c'est
pour les pour leur permettre de se
réintroduire dans la société
donc c'est donc la valeur de
l'emprisonnement alors qu'il faut voir
si on met les gens en prison pour les
punir
je passe à la même valeur qu'un
privilégiant le petit garçon à la lutte
résultat à l'intérieur les tribunes du
public était comble pour entendre le
garde des sceaux bien sûr pour écouter
aussi le député qui allait au nom du df
demander l'irrecevabilité du projet de
loi
dans une question préalable en fait
pascal clément c'est le nom du député en
question souhaitez-vous voir appliquer
la procédure du référendum pour ce
problème précis de la peine de mort
pourquoi tant de précipitation a déposé
ce projet puisque le candidat françois
mitterrand avait courageusement dit du
reste lors de sa campagne électorale
qu'il exercerait systématiquement son de
son droit de grâce
s'il était élu il est une autre raison
qui me pousse à exprimer ici ma
conviction que nous ne pouvons délibérer
valablement c'est la certitude que
l'abolition de la peine de mort ne peut
être envisagée que dans le cadre d'une
refonte du code pénal et un réexamen de
l'échelle des pères et c'est la vraie
question qui sera posée tout au long de
ce débat celle de la peine de
substitution
chaque député de l'opposition rpr udf
ayant la liberté de vote dans ce débat
c'est paradoxalement un rpr philippe
seguin qui a répondu à monsieur clément
se serait bloqué le débat que de le
ramener au niveau de nos émotions à
l'horreur de l'échafaud répondra
toujours celle des crimes qu'ils
conduisent
mes chers collègues la querelle sur
l'abolition et je rejoins sur ce point
monsieur clément doit se situer sur le
terrain pratique de la politique pénale
ou bien elle ne sera qu'un faux des
morts et justement nous devons constater
que si l'opinion demeure majoritairement
favorable à la peine de mort c'est parce
qu'elle attend que le châtiment suprême
jouent un rôle qui ne peut pas ou qu'il
ne peut plus
jouer nous devrons expliquer à l'opinion
tout en prenant acte bien sûr de sa
volonté de sécurité après une suspension
de 30 minutes à la demande du groupe
socialiste le président de la commission
des lois avait une forni a demandé que
la révision du code pénal envisagé soit
effective avant un an
le garde des sceaux qui souhaitaient un
répit de deux ou trois ans n'a pas
encore répondu à cette requête
mesdames messieurs bonsoir
la guillotine est hors la loi en france
la peine de mort est abolie
l'assemblée nationale a voté en première
lecture le projet de loi que lui avait
présenté le ministre de la justice
robert badinter ce vote historique a eu
lieu à 18h30 regardé personne ne demande
plus à voter le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin sur
l'article 1er qui je le rappelle était
ainsi libellé la peine de mort est
abolie nombre de votants 487 suffrages
exprimés 480,2 majorité absolue 240 2 ou
3 169 contre 116
l'assemblée nationale a adopté il ya
cent ans jour pour jour mouret victor
hugo l'écrivain poète et homme politique
pensait que le vendredi est un jour
néfaste il est mort le vendredi 22 mai
1885 l'assemblée de l'époque dans
laquelle il ne comptait pas que des amis
lui a voté pourtant à l'unanimité moins
deux voix quand même des funérailles
nationales
aujourd'hui un hommage lui est rendu
dans de nombreux pays du monde comme la
chine et le vietnam
à paris le sénat a honoré sa mémoire et
ce soir le garde des sceaux robert
badinter est redevenu avocat pour
plaider en faveur d'un homme de liberté
c'est en 1848
stimulante dans débat qui commence sur
la peine de mort du gourou calatayud et
exclame xviiie siècle à gouvy la torture
xixème siècle abolira sûrement la peine
de mort voyez une scène de tromper que
d'un siège
et le 21ème siècle alors abolira quoi
retraite
à écouter
peut-être il être dur à une
une autre idée
mais
vous me permettrez de vous dire plus
le garde des sceaux prononcer ce soir à
la sorbonne un dommage victor hugo on se
souvient que pendant son procès en 1977
patrick henry n'avait sauvé sa tête que
grâce à l'intervention de ses avocats
dont maître robert badinter il avait
fait une robert badinter de ce procès un
vrai plaidoyer contre la peine de mort
et les jurés l'avait suivie aujourd'hui
encore robert badinter interrogé par
yasmina faber se souvient quand j'ai
appris sa libération conditionnelle
je me suis souvenu de ses dernières
paroles à la cour d'assises le président
venait de lire la décision tuméfaction
et l'émotion immense
tous croyaient ou presque qu'ils
seraient condamnés à mort dans que fait
qu'il n'ait pas été suscité des
mouvements passionné depuis l'ordre
serré tablier et le président lui ai dit
patrick henry la cour a fait preuve
votre égard d'une grande mansuétude
souvenez vous en et soyez en digne et
patrick henry qui permet beaucoup de mal
parler a dit en réponse une voix blanche
ou encore je vous remercie
je n'aurai pas le regretter et c'est cet
engagement là je pense qu'il a tenus au
long du quart de siècle écoulé et c'est
ça qui a amené la libération
conditionnelle il a tenu sa parole
[Musique]